what do you guys think
i'm i'm just curious from the men do you
guys know anybody that's a guy that's
been so i know you said you've been
slapped yeah i've been snapped do you
know is it common would you say among
men like to have been hit by a girl
um probably more common than we think we
just don't report it because we're too
ashamed because we don't tell each other
exactly
that their wife or their girlfriend hit
them yeah they're not going to say that
exactly and what about you guys like do
you feel like it's common among your
female friends to be like
i don't personally know anybody oh wait
actually i do know i know one person
but i know one girl and like more than
one guy like i know more than one guy
that's been like hit and i know probably
one girl so like in my personal life
like i know more guys than girls that
that's happened too what about you guys
i mean
with the people in my life it's pretty
even like i know quite a bit of women
and men who have both been abused in
their relationships and
both of them have equally opened up to
me about being abused
um
it does hurt a little bit more though
i'm not gonna lie to hear about men
getting abused because then it's like
i don't know like it's kind of it's
weird to see
because that shows you that women have
no fear in them
when it comes to attacking a man yeah
like me like you know no matter what who
if someone were to like come at me first
i'm always gonna defend myself i will
fight you like i am a man myself right
right but it does scare me to see that
women
attack men when they're not provoked to
in the first place or they're not being
hit first
and i've seen it like quite a few times
and it even happened with my own parents
like my mom used to beat up on my dad
very early on in the relationship and my
dad never did anything about it and mind
you my dad is huge he's six foot two
buff like he could fight he could defend
himself but my mom is a small
five-foot-four
stature woman so can i say the reason
why that might have happened is because
your dad knew the implications of him
hitting back
well my dad doesn't lay his hands on
women
period yeah no i know that but he does
understand that there would have been a
problem if he did say something to
someone else in the family because
unfortunately my family was quick to
take my mother's side not knowing my mom
was the villain the whole time but do
you think your dad knew that if he did
retaliate physically that it would look
so bad on him yeah because my mom has
lied about my dad hitting her and i
obviously i was there
so i never saw him lay hands on her
and i know what type of person he is
obviously because i've been around him
24 7. i'm a daddy's girl but that
doesn't mean that i'm gonna defend him
if he was hitting my mom right you know
like i see i see [ __ ] for what it is
that's just a fact about me i appreciate
you sharing that because not a lot of
women would say that about their dads
yeah you know they will say the opposite
naturally defend their mom saying oh my
oh my dad was
yeah you need to say that that's really
quite honest i'll be honest my mom was
trifling i have seen a lot of trifling
women in my life unfortunately and it's
disappointing
but
luckily a lot of the men in my life at
least that had gone through that like
they handled it really well like i would
say like for guys that got attacked
consistently and like really were not
the villain in the story like they
handled it really well
but don't you think like it's easy see
that's the thing like it's easy for the
woman to be the victim do you know what
i mean in these kind of situations it's
because they're already naturally
smaller and they automatically assume
like
you're a man you're this big and you're
this strong it shouldn't it doesn't hurt
does it like but then what happens when
women
understand that they can be seen as a
victim and they have an ego
and they have narcissistic traits or
whatever i think it turns out worse
do you know what i mean because if you
know that
it's that whole thing of
if you're a leader of a country and you
know you can't be touched you just might
be out of control because you know no
one can touch you yeah i mean i mean how
that works psychologically yeah yeah
humans are not built to have power
naturally like the stanford prison
experiment proves that easily i think
humans are humans are built our power
they're not
psychologically they're not don't argue
with me on this
okay so okay so make me understand i
would agree with you so what do you mean
are we how about power with constraints
yes so that's why that's what i was
saying what do you mean
you mean yeah there has to be there has
to be rules and sets and sort of
barriers so for example like like
balance of power okay yeah
balances yeah because power yeah i think
they are yeah ultimate power no because
it's cool for example in the persian
empire
the king could not do anything without
him getting i think approval from his uh
advisors
because they realized that hang on a
minute if we give one man absolute power
he can absolutely abuse that we don't
even have to go that's why we're back we
can just look at america now and how
the president like of the us they have
to go through several checks and
approval through several steps before
they can pass anything that they want to
do then how the hell did i become a
president then
what that doesn't have to do with me
anyway
seriously though like these rules have
to be set in place because humans
naturally especially the average human
cannot handle power even if it's the
tiniest bit of it like so do you guys
think that if a man or a woman hits a
man he should be able to hit back
because
i i feel like
if a girl is to the point like she
brings out a knife i feel like knock her
out
i just like genuinely like i'm sorry if
you bring a knife to this fight knock
her knock that equal rights equalizer
there's a general rule general rule no
but obviously there are circumstances
whereby if someone like you mentioned if
someone has a knife do you hit that
person i think ideally if i was in that
circumstance you tried to wrestle her
and pin that down
and then you might you might end up like
dude possibly
you're like
over here
[Music]
i'm not talking about nice women i'm
talking about the [ __ ]
that wants to happen the narrative would
say
big black guy kills woman okay no
context whatsoever right right yeah okay
so we're gonna jump to that immediately
self defense 100
if you're defending yourself because
someone's coming at you of course you're
going to defend yourself like i don't
want to die and no one wants to die like
yeah defend yourself yeah but i don't
condone violence full stop so if
someone's hitting someone just walk away
just leave that situation get out of
there but it's easier that's said than
done isn't it because when you're an
abusive relationship it's not just about
the physical abuse it's about the mental
torture that you are put through
all the time continuously and i think in
some ways and i'm not condoning this at
all why sometimes people lash out and
are physically violent is because
mentally and emotionally spiritually
they've been abused so much
that literally their soul is is crushed
they're a shell of a person now as i
said i'm not condoning it but this is
human psyche isn't
you said should a man be able to hit
back mm-hmm yes
i'm with you
i mean it's that simple like i will say
i don't i think there's levels right so
if like i feel like girls like play hits
sometimes you don't even know yeah
but like i feel like if she's
say it pal say it yeah
i feel like if she brings a knife to the
fight you should hit her i but make sure
you record that stuff so she's not
saying something like that because she
gonna
but i think if if a woman thinks that
she can physically
um
abuse a man
then she's obviously a little bit
delusional oh yeah because physically
men are stronger than women
right but
that but then there's an age-old thing
of
if you want to control somebody no
matter how big and strong they are you
just control their mind
the question is to see sarah is this
though even if a woman is beating up the
man has the man allowed it to happen
because
has he not set boundaries himself he's
psychologically beaten down before she
can actually hit him so even if you're a
strong man that sets boundaries do you
think no if you set boundaries in from
the beginning if you know how to set
boundaries then you know how to leave at
the end of the day but somebody who
claims that they set boundaries but
still stick with that bs is definitely
not strong on their boundaries and
definitely doesn't know how to stand for
themselves so could the beats not be
resentment because the woman's thinking
this guy gets me it lets me get away
with stuff so i'm just going to test the
boundaries because i want drugs that's
exactly how it goes that's exactly how
abuse works it just keeps leveling up as
time goes along they like to see how
much control they can have over you
until it comes to a point where they
have full and total control over you and
you have nothing you can't do anything
about it
like your family probably tried to talk
you out of the relationship you're
friends you probably had therapy and
you're still there like why do you why
do you think people stay in toxic
relationships they they they can't
mentally leave
manipulation yeah manipulation and it
stems from narcissism doesn't it
they're broken down to the point where
they physically can't leave because
mentally they're elsewhere they've gone
it's it yeah
do you think that
there's any responsibility on the person
being abused for not leaving when they
do have the choice assuming that person
isn't threatening them if they like they
have the right to leave i mean yeah but
it's like stockholm syndrome isn't it
yeah i mean like yeah you can
once you build up as like i've always
said the mind is stronger than a body
anyway do you know what i mean and and
to control somebody's mind
no matter how big they are
you have control over that person
doesn't matter how much muscles they've
got or how tall they are if you control
their mind you will be the one in
control exactly so for example we always
think who is what is the strongest
animal in the king in the animal kingdom
it's probably the elephant elephant but
why is the lion the king of the jungle
attitude it's actually the ant
but anyway um
wait why
they can hold over 100 times their
weight
physically
yeah but they're not going to beat a
lion
no obviously not but hypothetically
they're technically one of the strongest
oh you mean like the strongest okay okay
but what i was gonna say before um damn
y'all messed me up cause y'all kept
going and going
i was trying to jump in
but then i got scared to jump in the
ring i think
we were either talking about hitting
back or we were talking about um why
like people stay oh yeah accountability
the issue with that is that
90 of the reason we are the way we are
today is because of our childhood
if you come from a home where you are
used to abuse whether it be verbal
physical mental whatever it may be
you're going to be susceptible to it
later on in your
future intimate relationships even in
your friendships do you feel like
there's a certain age that you can't
blame your childhood anymore
no because i think
i don't think what happens as a child
obviously
always will always to some degree always
stick with us yeah that we choose
whether we're gonna let that control us
for the rest of our lives or not but
yeah for example if you were abused as a
child right that's always going to be
with you it depends if it's if it's
living in your conscious or subconscious
exactly because a lot of the time our
conscious behaviors are uh because of
our subconscious right but if you are
consciously saying oh i'm only doing
this because of my childhood and yeah
you you're typically consciously
choosing that you're going to be an
[ __ ]
you want to make excuses
okay at that point but genuinely it
really depends on when you decide to
unpack the trauma right because like you
know when it comes to being from a
minority family you know like
i promise you all of my aunts and uncles
have been abused at some point by my
grandmother or grandfather you know
whoever it may be it's very common
especially in the caribbean
um but my dad only really started
unpacking the problems behind that
within the last 10 years i would say my
mom hasn't done that at all you know
and
if she were to sit down with me today
and be like i realized what i went
through in my childhood was messed up
and this is why i am the way i am today
i would think that she has every right
to say that and i would think that she
has every right to blame her childhood
because she only just realized no i i
understand that i just think like
like i understand saying okay this is
the cause of that behavior and that's
good to know but i just think over a
certain age you can't make the excuse of
your childhood anymore yeah no like you
like that is the problem then
i think okay so if you know you're like
this because of your childhood
if you're aware and you use it as an
excuse that's when it becomes a problem
right because i have been in
relationships where people will be like
i got trust issues like
my mom beat me when i was seven like
okay so you're aware of that why not
unpack that well i'm like what did i
come back together later i do what did i
do to you you you
maturity comes into the place whereby
you acknowledge you have this side of
you because of past trauma which you
can't control right you have a
responsibility to say okay this is how i
feel i'm not gonna put myself in a
situation like a relationship whereby
these traumas that haven't been dealt
with could surface up and damage
sabotage their relationship
i guess you just shouldn't be in a
relationship if you haven't dealt with
your own demons in the first place i
mean everyone's got demons but it's
whether or not they resurface constantly
and it comes back to traumas again from
childhood are you a narcissist have you
built up this wall are you protected but
don't we all have demons usually that's
what we do that's when people get into
relationships the most when they're like
most psychologically [ __ ] up because
they can't find love anywhere else and
the mistake is the mistake is that my
partner is going to be my cure
and that's what messes people up
have you noticed that the most
narcissistic people jump from
relationship to relationship to relation
is that just me or do you know
that's a common thing so here's the
thing with me right so i was in a
relationship from when i was 18 to 25
like seven years six and a half seven
years right
and then
i was single i was single for like
six months and then i got into another
relationship and i was in that for like
two and a half
then i was single again for like maybe a
year and a half and then i got in my
next relationship i was in that for ten
years okay and
people say oh you're 40. like shouldn't
you have settled down by now and i'm
like you know what i was in a 10-year
relationship right took it out of me and
now i'm like you know what you need to
chill
because that jumping from relationship
to relationship
kind of made me realize that
i had a i had an epiphany one day and i
was like i've spent like over half of my
life like half of my life in
relationships like who the hell are you
bro do you know what i mean and i think
it's not until you kind of like
have that realization that you can be
okay with yourself
do you know